re
いっ
幹事長どうくっ道
始めた皆さん紙粘土してますか紙に2勝館倉庫型ね退け守らなのだからこれ
きたたことありますかカビネットというものは普通の年度とは違って開封して形を作っ
て放置すると
光景物になってしまう
つまり紙粘土があればどんな形の固形物でも作ることがず質的にを可能でございます
それ故やっかみエンド全16中古車ございました
ああああああああ
多すぎィ僕は今までの前世で紙粘土いろんなものを送ってきたんですけども
今回は紙粘土で家を作ってみようと思い
紙粘土で家を作れることはまあ理論的には可能なんですけどもいいから固形物で今日と
いうものが存在します
で紙粘土で家をつくったとしても多すぎてドエンってなるかもしれないし
的にうまいことを作ればもう綺麗な紙粘土のおうちが出来るかもしれない
でも普通に立っても無理なのでそこで金具みたいなのを買ってあり年度の補強をして
いきながらちゃんと
痛みはね完全に紙粘土のお家だよみたいな感じで作っていければいいなと思っており
ます果たし
紙粘土の器作ることができるのかだよええ
無理だと思うんだよないやいやありますけどねいい
間はいという意味で紙粘土セミ160分としました
でこれ加減では2種類あるんですけどこれがちょっと重めの強度が高い文年度
ってこちらがかなくてよく伸びる組年と2種類ので止まるんですけどもう家の下の部分
がずれる固いヘッドを使ってか止めて言って上の部分やねとパワー
軽い紙ので作っていこうと思いましたえっ
てないかーっはいでは早速作っていきますまずは
作る紙粘土のお家の間取りを決めていきましょうあまり大きいを作ろうと覚えすぎると
足りなくなっちゃうねは ldk と思いますの多分1/2くらいで良いと思います
作ってきますあとやっぱすごいよちゃんと動ける
これで的な形を作って放置しておくと固まります
ああああああ
一流なこれ
[音楽]
どんどんやっていきます
ていますね
愛知だけで間取りは完成しましただいたいこれくらいの大きさだったら a 3160
個の紙粘土で食べると思いますでここはちょっと積み重ねていきましょうはいで今
ちょっとこういう感じでさせていったんですけども
多分
倒れますこのようにさらに積み重ねて行くと絶対触れるんで
立案者のと年度に網を子食い込ませておいて補強しながら立てていきました
いやいいすぐ紙粘土なんで amiga ちゃんといまっていきます超的には全然問題
ないと思います
いきます
5これで土台は多分大丈夫だと思います子供はずっと積み重ねていくんですけど
めっちゃここが入り口玄関の予定でございます
どんどん建てていきましょう
土台となる大きいの年度の設置は終了しましたこれが基本的に土台になります必要隙間
なくなるべく時間をかけて丁寧に固めていったのであとは残りの発表とのこと紙粘土を
以下に載せて崩れないうちに家まで完成させるかがポイントでございます
[音楽]
ガラス蛇腹回軽いをめちゃくちゃをやらないんですね
これならなんかもうアミド化にペタペタ二行だけどいいレベルです
メッツが0
見えたーーーはぁ
me
ブーム
[音楽]
はぁ
大丈夫ですとに壁は完成しますちょっと高さはバレバレなんですけどもう店さは屋根が
完成して前にを乗せてから
を出していこうと思います
[音楽]
ちょっと待ってねー
いやねどうやっておけばいいこれ屋根が一番難しくねだってだってたと2分待ってパン
で屋根どうすればいい
食べやんねーはもうこのペタペタ作っててもダメなんでやや別で作って付けた屋根を
この上にバーンっておこうと思います
はいというわけで屋根が完成しました
多分紙粘土だけど今日だと
[音楽]
ブーブー位
の
まっす
それわけねーか3連投の家完成しましたーー
ハッハー
[音楽]
はいで大事なのは実際に入れるか動画です帰れなかったらもうもうと思わないですかね
いただきまーすはぁっ
ファイル n さんやけどほんとちゃんと誘導して出来てると思います
ちゃんともう壁この壁壁壁全部ちゃんの壁として成立しています
出窓この窓から顔が出せます竜ヶ馬場おっ
入れましたーーー
ん陰で燃えたよ
子供が遊ぶいえぐらいの財布には抜き取るではないでしょうか
はいというわけで今日は大量の紙粘土で家をつくりました
大変でしたそして今回ですね cm 会などいろいろ出演した shape スマホ
通学の企画の一環で私外れシャツを
リーカーの先生ということで今回この動画を作りました
で今回ですねこう
の紙粘土で作ってみたい以外の様々な実験も行っていますのでぜひ皆さんそちらをご覧
下さい
そして私はじめシャツを理科担当の先生以外にも像前20名以上のアソコの c 先生
たちがいますのでぜひ他の先生の授業も見てください
どれも面白いと思います同様の概要欄からチェックしてみてくださいみんな
無駄の10件
なんてないんだよやることにガンガー
[音楽]